Новини дня «heute» з Яною Парайґіс.
Доброго вечора.
Як німецькі футболістки готуються до
завтрашнього півфіналу УЄФА Євро-2022 серед жінок?
Про це розповість Норберт Леман.
Найважливіші теми сьогодні:
Компроміс щодо надзвичайного плану ЄС:
держави-члени повинні з серпня
добровільно зменшити споживання газу на 15%.
Критичне становище: у Бранденбурзі
крони дерев займаються полум’ям одна за одною.
Туристи змушені залишити територію
Саксонської Швейцарії.
Вихід Москви:
Росія, очевидно, хоче побудувати власну
космічну станцію
та вийти з проєкту Міжнародної космічної станції.
Що робити, якщо Росія більше не постачатиме газу?
ЄС хоче бути готовим до цього.
Тому сьогодні на позачерговому засіданні
міністри енергетики погодили надзвичайний план.
Мета: заощадити 15% газу до березня наступного року.
Добровільно.
Водночас є певні нюанси:
у плані щодо економії газу є численні винятки.
Флоріан Нойган розповість про компроміс.
Найбільшою несподіванкою у Брюсселі
сьогодні є, мабуть, те,
що чогось не вистачає.
А саме: звичних суперечок.
Єдність міністрів енергетики, ймовірно, пов’язана з тим,
що Росія робить саме те, про що Комісія ЄС
попереджала уже декілька днів:
вона знову має намір постачати менше газу.
Це рішення є політично вмотивованим.
Саме тому розумною стратегією є скорочення
нашого попиту на газ як запобіжний захід.
Надзвичайний план щодо газу передбачає, що
держави ЄС від серпня до березня наступного року
зменшать споживання газу на 15%.
Проте погодження стало можливим лише
завдяки багатьом виняткам -
як для окремих держав, так і для цілих
промислових секторів.
Турбувати може те, що є так багато винятків,
що ми так довго вестимемо підрахунки щодо
них усіх, що криза вже й скінчиться.
Це, звісно, було б жахливо.
Також сумнівно, чи достатньо узгодженої сьогодні мети.
Очільник Міжнародного енергетичного агентства
стверджує, що цього замало.
Якщо все інше вдасться ідеально,
тоді нам потрібно скоротити споживання газу
в Європі на 20%,
щоб запобігти великим проблемам взимку.
Однак у Брюсселі сьогодні відчувається полегшення:
уникнути поразки вдалося.
З одного боку, сьогодні ЄС здивував своїх критиків
компромісом щодо суперечливого
питання енергетики.
З іншого боку, сьогоднішнє рішення є нічим іншим,
як оголошенням намірів.
Зобов’язання заощаджувати газ має ухвалюватися
державами ЄС відповідною більшістю голосів,
а досягти цього буде значно складніше.
Насамперед від великих держав, передусім
від Німеччини, зараз залежить те,
чи досягне ЄС своєї мети щодо
заощадження добровільно.
Наскільки важливою є міжнародна співпраця,
можна також побачити на прикладі газової мережі
Німеччини, особливо на півдні,
де надзвичайна ситуація з газом може сильно
зашкодити промисловості.
Особливість цього регіону:
Баварія залежна від величезного газосховища «Гайдах»,
яке розташоване в сусідній Австрії.
Наразі газ із цього сховища постачається
тільки до німецької мережі.
Але в майбутньому ймовірним є те, що також
Австрія користатиметься газом із цього сховища.
Олександр Поль розповість,
як ситуацію зараз бачать у Баварії.
Газосховище «Гайдах» поблизу Зальцбурга -
одне із найбільших підземних сховищ в Європі.
Це газосховище забезпечує газом усю
південну Німеччину, передусім Баварію.
Тепер, коли Росія продовжує скорочувати постачання,
Австрія починає також претендувати на газ з «Гайдаха».
В Австрії ми маємо одне із найсучасніших
сховищ в Європі, газосховище «Гайдах».
І в цій ситуації неможливою є відмова
від системного та довгострокового використання
цього сховища.
Питання, чи вистачить газу всім,
є передусім важливим для баварської промисловості.
Баварія отримує майже половину газу з Росії -
більше, ніж інші федеральні землі.
Усі підприємства,
від хімічної промисловості до машинобудування,
значною мірою залежать від цих постачань.
Напередодні зими прем’єр-міністр Баварії Зедер
закликає до обов’язкової угоди з Австрією.
Досі немає чинної відповідно до міжнародного права
угоди щодо відбору
та закачування газу зі сховища «Гайдах».
Поки що все це є лише оголошенням намірів.
Треба чітко домовитися,
що відбір газу стосується не тільки Австрії,
але так само й Баварії.
У Баварії теж є власні менші сховища.
Згідно з заявами відповідального
Міністерства економіки,
ці газосховища досі заповнюються газом.
Минулого тижня рівень заповнення
збільшився від 56,2% до 59,6%.
Експерти сумніваються, чи цього вистачить.
Основною проблемою може бути те,
що ми не зможемо заповнити сховища настільки,
щоб забезпечити себе газом на зиму.
Зараз це є справжньою небезпекою.
Наступного тижня Маркус Зедер і його
міністр економіки
хочуть відвідати газосховище «Гайдах».
Чи будуть там укладені конкретні
домовленості - покаже час.
У майбутньому охочі придбати електромобіль
отримуватимуть значно менше державних субсидій.
Зокрема, розмір субсидій для електромобілів,
які коштують менше 40 000 євро,
становитиме 4500 замість 6000 євро.
Для плагін-гібридних електромобілів, тобто тих, що
мають і електромотор, і двигун внутрішнього згоряння,
субсидію скасують повністю наприкінці цього року.
Завтра це рішення обговорюватиметься в уряді.
Ситуація з лісовими пожежами у східній Німеччині
погіршується.
Після декількох днів спеки й надзвичайної посухи
у Бранденбурзі та Саксонії почалися пожежі.
У національному парку Саксонська Швейцарія
поширюється лісова пожежа.
Ця пожежа спалахнула в сусідній Чехії.
У Бад-Шандав оголошено про загрозу стихійного лиха.
У Бранденбурзі багатьом людям уже довелося
залишити свої домівки.
Особливо постраждав регіон навколо Фалькенберґа.
Детальніше - Корнелія Шіменц та Ян Меєр.
Води ніколи не буває достатньо
в зоні лісової пожежі.
Тому фермер Уве Воннеберґер возить пожежникам
в Фалькенберзі-на-Ельстері додаткову воду для гасіння
на своєму розсіювачеві гною.
Я допомагаю пожежній команді з водою.
У моїй цистерні 18 500 літрів води,
що є величезною підмогою для пожежних бригад.
Гелікоптери Бундесверу та федеральної поліції також
допомагають гасити найбільш руйнівну лісову пожежу
в Бранденбурзі за останні п'ять десятиліть.
Ферма поблизу Кельса, де вирощують поросят,
охоплена вогнем.
Багато тварин гине.
З трьох населених евакуювали жителів.
Майже 300 людей змушені залишити свої домівки
та господарства.
Майже 20 з них знайшли порятунок
від полум'я, що наближається,
в актовій залі Фалькенберґу.
Причина пожежі поки невідома.
Міністр внутрішніх справ Бранденбурґа стверджує, що
за останні кілька тижнів тут декілька разів
спалахували пожежі.
На жаль, ситуація зараз така, що ми не можемо
з’ясувати 60% причин масштабних та лісових пожеж.
Здебільшого причинами є людська необережність та,
на жаль, також навмисні підпали.
Зараз полум'я більше не поширюється.
Людям можна повертатися додому.
Але пожежна бригада й надалі чергуватиме всю ніч.
Райське місце для відпочинку охоплене вогнем.
У декількох місцях національного парку
Богемська Швейцарія,
прямо на кордоні з Саксонією,
висота вогню сягає одного метра.
Тепер полум'я охопило й Саксонську Швейцарію.
Сотні пожежників борються з лихом.
Через те, що сили та засоби обмежені,
через труднощі дістатися до місця пожежі,
а також через брак води там,
наші заходи наразі обмежені лише
стримуванням вогню.
Навіть для цього потрібно багато людських ресурсів,
мотики, скребачки, лопати й заступи.
Зараз Бундесвер залучив чотири гелікоптери, щоб
допомогти гасити пожежу.
У Бад-Шандав оголошено про загрозу стихійного лиха.
Туристів закликають терміново покинути цю місцевість.
У Саксонській Швейцарії планується введення
заборони ходити до всіх лісів регіону впродовж
всього дня.
Роботи ще триватимуть деякий час.
І варто згадати наш нещодавній досвід
пожежі в Бастаї:
пожежу доводилося гасити
ще багато днів після її приборкання.
Тож ці роботи триватимуть досить довго.
Вогонь важко приборкати, оскільки ліс
надзвичайно сухий.
Крім того, дерева сильно пошкоджені
нашестям короїдів.
Сильні вітри продовжують розпалювати летючі іскри,
так що взяти під контроль пожежу
у Саксонській Швейцарії поки не вдалося.
Німеччина знову надала Україні важке озброєння.
Зокрема, йдеться про вже обіцяні три ракетні
системи залпового вогню Mars II
та ще три самохідні гаубиці Panzerhaubitze 2000.
Тим часом Росія знову бомбардувала порт
на півдні України.
Унаслідок цього зруйновано інфраструктуру
в доках міста Миколаєва, повідомляє Київ.
Росія також обстріляла ракетами
село поблизу портового міста Одеса.
Україна говорить про обстріл житлових будинків
цивільного населення.
Москва стверджує, що там зберігалася зброя.
У цьому регіоні Одеси наразі перебуває
наш кореспондент Дара Гасанзаде.
Саме через ці порти найближчими днями
планується початок експортування зерна.
Заробіток багатьох людей
у цій місцевості залежить від
портів і моря.
Наприклад, від риболовлі.
Але під час війни тут працювати неможливо.
Дара Гасанзаде розповість про вплив цих подій
на галузь рибальства.
З початком повномасштабної війни
рибальське підприємство Олександра Філіповича
припинило свою роботу.
Тут працювали 150 рибалок.
Але зараз молоді хлопці в армії, а старші чоловіки
працюють у Румунії.
Залишився охоронець, його собака та начальник.
Прислів’я каже:
набезриб’їі рак риба.
Ось так і в нас.
Частина багатства України зберігається
навпроти, у зернових силосах порту.
Нам заборонено знімати це з міркувань безпеки.
Незабаром звідти відпливуть перші кораблі.
Флагман Олександра, «Ґріголетті», змушений
залишатися в порту.
Рибальський одяг для зимового сезону досі висить
після початку вторгнення.
Як закидати сіті, коли в морі плавають міни?
Один корабель Олександра вже втрачено.
Його було пришвартовано в окупованому
Росією Херсоні.
Ще важче 63-річний Олександр пережив
анексію Криму.
У нього конфіскували 70 відсотків кораблів.
Втратою для України також стали
рибальські угіддя Криму.
Найважливішим для мене зараз є те,
щоб люди залишилися
живими і чим більше, тим краще.
Погано, коли втрачаєш бізнес.
Але це зовсім інша проблема.
Старі рибалки Чорноморська чекають у гавані,
але вид на інший бік гавані вселяє їм трохи надії.
З початку повномасштабної війни в Україні все більше
зростає напруження між Росією та
західними країнами.
Сьогодні стало відомо, що
Росія фактично
покидає Міжнародну космічну станцію.
Після 2024 року співпраця
у космічному просторі має припинитися.
Натомість Москва хоче
побудувати власну космічну станцію.
Про це повідомив новий голова
Російського космічного агентства.
Подробиці від Томаса Гонзіора.
МКС - вихід у відкритий космос.
Минуло всього п'ять днів, як
вони почали працювати  разом:
Олег Артем'єв і Саманта Крістофоретті.
Росіянин і європейка – далеко від Землі,
далеко від війни і політичної конфронтації.
Але навіть у космосі співпраці має
бути покладено край.
Так хоче Москва,
причиною стали також санкції проти
російської космічної промисловості.
Рішення ухвалено -
ми залишаємо станцію у 2024 році.
Я думаю, до того часу ми почнемо
будувати російську космічну базу.
Це означає, що Москва могла б від'єднати один модуль
і продовжувати працювати самостійно.
Дотепер всі працювали разом.
Росія була від самого початку.
Під час планування та будівництва у 90-х роках.
У складі першого екіпажу 2000 року.
Один американець, двоє росіян.
Відтоді склад змінювався.
Сталим залишалося одне: представники
Росії завжди були на борту.
Завжди це були
спільні дослідження, спільні переживання,
радощі та перемоги.
Ми виросли в зовсім різних умовах.
Але, незважаючи на це, ми добре співпрацюємо,
це одна з найважливіших речей,
якій ми вчимося, перебуваючи на космічній станції.
Мир. Розуміння. Прогрес.
І тепер невідомо, що буде далі з форпостом людства.
Повернемось до новин Німеччини.
Рік тому у Вюрцбурзі
невідомий напав
з ножем на перехожих у центрі міста.
Загинуло три жінки,
ще дев'ятеро осіб поранено.
Сьогодні місцевий суд виніс рішення.
Обвинувачений, родом із Сомалі,
тривалий час перебуває у психіатричній лікарні.
Репортаж Петри Нойбауер.
Чоловік із Сомалі постійно чув голоси,
які наказали йому вбивати.
Через прояви параноїдної шизофренії місцевий суд
Вюрцбурга виніс рішення
про безстрокове перебування обвинуваченого у
психіатричній лікарні.
Палата аргументувала це тим, що
з одного боку, обвинувачений на момент
скоєння злочину був неосудним через його психічне
захворювання, з іншого ж боку, він
становить загрозу для
суспільства і потрібно запобігти майбутнім злочинам.
Таким, як минулого року,
коли чоловік у неадекватному стані
напав на людей.
Загинули три жінки,
дев'ятеро осіб поранено.
Перехожі намагались його зупинити,
поки вбивцю не затримала поліція.
Рішення суду - сигнал для захисту,
позбутись упереджень.
Це не подарунок для вбивці, що
його визнали неосудним,
а, за словами голови суду,
перебування в психіатричній лікарні
за статтею 63 КК -
це найгірше покарання кримінального права.
Судовий процес дуже допоміг потерпілим,
які зараз також виступають як позивачі.
Якщо жертв, постраждалих почують,
ця справа може бути закрита
наприкінці дня.
А сомалійцю залишається лише сподіватися,
що в клініці його божевіллю колись зможуть зарадити.
Lufthansa скасувала на завтра
майже всі рейси в аеропортах
Франкфурта та Мюнхена.
Від цього постраждали більше ніж 130 000 пасажирів.
Також не відбулись рейси у багатьох інших аеропортах.
Причиною є попереджувальний страйк
наземного персоналу, що триватиме до ранку четверга.
Страйк припадає на гарячий сезон відпусток
в аеропортах.
Так профсоюзи вимагають
збільшення зарплат на 9,5%.
А зараз поговоримо про технічний шедевр.
Або про європейське незадоволення.
Для кого як.
За 45 хвилин відкриється новий міст
в Адріатичному морі:
два з половиною кілометри поєднають
Хорватію з Хорватією.
Точніше:
північну частину з
південною в регіоні Дубровник.
Територія Боснії розмежовує півострів
з метериковою частиною.
Більшу частину фінансування проєкт отримав від ЄС.
Проте міст зводила китайська компанія
за досить сумнівних умов.
Репортаж Брітти Гілперт.
Це не лише мрія відпочивальників:
Пелєшацький міст не лише з'єднує
дві частини країни,
а й є технічним шедевром.
Бо ще під час будівництва йому довелось
витримати не один шторм і землетруси.
Опори моста сягають глибини 130 метрів,
що є світовим рекордом.
Він також достатньо високий для великих кораблів.
85% будівництва фінансувалося ЄС,
але будівництво велося китайською
державною компанією.
За словами представника замовника,
їхня пропозиція була дешевшою на 20%.
Вони обіцяли набагато вигіднішу ціну,
крім того, завершити будівництво
на шість місяців раніше
ніж конкуренти.
Однак за певний час стало зрозуміло, що
китайським робітникам заборонено залишати
свій робочий табір.
Також є свідчення, що вони не
отримували обіцяної зарплати
бо був наявний демпінг.
Було неможливо провести ретельну перевірку.
Неприємність для ЄС.
Рабські умови праці фінансуються ЄС.
Це неприпустимо.
Крім того, ми не можемо дозволити
зруйнувати європейську будівельну промисловість,
надавши китайцям можливість
знизити ціни за рахунок субвенцій.
Міст полегшив життя відпочивальників.
Тепер їм не потрібно двічі перетинати кордон.
Для ЄС він став попередженням:
нові правила ускладнюють китайським
компаніям доступ до ринку ЄС.
Тепер про ЧЄ з футболу.
Норберте, завтра ввечері все вирішиться:
У півфіналі Німеччина зіграє проти Франції.
Досі настрій у німецькому футбольному союзі DFB був
чудовим.
Проте сьогоднішній вечір приніс дійсно погані новини:
Нападниця Клара Бюль, авторка важливого
голу в грі з Іспанією (1:0),
отримала позитивний тест на коронавірус.
Інші 22 гравчині, на щастя, здорові.
Вінгерка з мюнхенської «Баварії»,
а на цьому турнірі вже авторка гольових
передач і нападниця,
вже не допоможе команді.
Але за концепцією тренерки збірної
у грі проти сильної та швидкої Франції змін не буде.
Ми будемо дотримуватися плану на гру та
грати у свій футбол,
ми будемо йти до кінця і
використовувати всі помилки суперниць.
Ймовірно, на місці сильної у поєдинках і
дриблінгу Клари Бюль
гратиме Юле Бранд.
У кожній грі на ЧЄ
на полі замість Бюль з'являлася новенька
команди «Вольфсбург».
Випробувати альтернативні схеми нападу
можна буде сьогодні в Мілтон-Кінз.
Там відбудеться фінальне тренування німецької збірної.
Початок о 19:30.
Сьогодні ввечері у півфіналі зустрінеться перша пара:
Англія - Швеція.
Збірна Англії «Three Lionesses» має чітку мету:
вперше стати чемпіонками Європи
за підтримки
фантастичних англійських вболівальників.
Та шведки, які посідають друге місце
у світовому рейтинзі, - сильний суперник,
тож варто очікувати захоплюючої гри.
Інтерес в країні до гри національної жіночої збірної
настільки зріс,
що тепер за їхніми тренуваннями
можна стежити наживо на каналі у Twitter.
«Левиці» хочуть продовжити переможну серію,
як у грі з Іспанією,
де вони забили вирішальний гол на останній хвилині.
А також і надалі «штампувати» голи.
На рахунку команди їх наразі 14.
Проте гравчині залишаються реалістками.
Ми маємо бути готовими до будь-якої гри,
залишатись зосередженими на грі,
а не на успіху.
Тричі поспіль англійська команда на великих турнірах
зазнавала невдачі, востаннє у півфіналі.
Настав час розірвати цю серію невдач.
Цецилія Уттруп Людвіг
перемогла у третьому етапі «Tour de France» серед жінок:
Датчанка подолала дистанцію у 133,6 км між
Реймсом і Еперне в спринті,
випередивши лідерку
загального заліку нідерландку Маріанне Вос.
Сьогодні також були падіння,
але не такі серйозні, як напередодні.
Це всі новини спорту.
Дякую, Норберте.
Тепер коротко про погоду: завтра на півночі
хмарно, на півдні ясно.
Більше про це Озден Терлі.
heute journal з Крістіаном Зіверсом
дивіться сьогодні о 23:15.
Щасти!
Вітаю, з вами прогноз погоди.
Суха погода збережеться у більшій частині Європи
суттєвих змін не очікується, бо до нас наближається
новий антициклон.
Але на межі з циклоном, який поступово відступає,
прийде прохолодне повітря і температура знизиться.
Вночі очікуються невеликі дощі,
на більшості території переважно сухо,
температура коливатиметься від 9°C до 13°C на півночі.
На південному заході буде прохолодніше,
у районі Рейна та Майна
прогнозуються 16°C.
Завтра на півночі хмарно, очікується
сильний вітер з північного заходу,
можливі штормові попередження.
На південному сході місцями
зливи та грози.
Температура коливатиметься від
25°C до 27°C  на півдні,
та від 17 °C до 20°C  у районі
Північнонімецької низовини.
У четвер пройдуть грози на півдні,
температура сягне позначки 31°C,
у п'ятницю місцями очікуються часті зливи та грози.
Гарного вечора.